[Music]
deaths of despair increases in mortality
caused by suicide addiction and
alcoholism as a term that describes the
crisis caused by job losses in
manufacturing and other heavy industries
several recent studies have suggested
that unemployment was a factor in these
deaths especially in regions like
Appalachia but a new study claims that
the real culprit may be coal mining
itself coal mines are associated with
injuries that often require treatment
with opioid painkillers the more opioid
use the greater the community's exposure
both legal and illegal resulting in
higher rates of addiction and death a
decline in coal employment was
associated with lower rates of opioid
deaths as the rate of coal planet Rises
so does opioid related mortality coal
mining that sometimes romanticize
despite its physical difficulty endanger
miners and industrial workers need and
deserve support after job loss but we
shouldn't forget the risks they endure
when we hear calls to bring back cold
what do you think is the best way to
help unemployed workers let us know in
the comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI